j'arrive pas à croire qu'on va se
retrouver coincé là-dessus pendant 10
jours ouais désolé de t'embarquer dans
cette galère soyez attentif si vous
voulez résoudre un crime vous devez
commencer par apprendre à voir par de
l'illusion les détails ont leur
importance la nuit dernière un de nos
passagers a été assassiné dans sa
cabineous de maeule c'est une montre qui
vaut plaques plus que tout ce que tu
fais quelqu'un doit le remettre à sa
place c'est pas toujours obligé d'être
toi mais fa bien nos équipes ont
renforcé la sécurité de sorte que ni
vous ni nos passagers n'ayez aucune
inquiétude à
avoir nous avons la chance d'avoir un
détective de renom à bord monsieur RF
scotw c'est pas vrai il faut que je me
présente dans 24 he interp montera à
bord de ce bateau et tu seras leur
unique suspect je l'ai pas tué je veux
t'aider Scott n'importe lequel d'entrex
a pu tuer la victime je vais interroger
chacun votre
tour parlez-moi un peu de vos
interactions avec la victime je l'ai pas
rencontré ce mec n'était qu'un pauvre
abrti où vous trouviez-vous entre minuit
et 8h du matin ça ne va pas plaire à ma
grand-mère j'ai jamais dit un truc pare
vous a dit ça c'est vraiment grotesque
il ne vaut mieux pas faire de nous des
ennemis pas d'alibi alors
excusez-moi tu es doué
branqu vous étiez déjà au courant d' peu
près tout ce que je viens de m vertu à
découvrir c'est plus amusant tout
couvrir par soi-même qu'attendez-vous de
moi alors vous voulez que
j'espionne je veux que tu me fasses
confiance les forces en jeu en ce moment
sont au-delà de tout ce que vous pouvez
imaginer il y a plusieurs milliards en
jeu c'est un puzzle on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour le
compléter il suffit de mettre les pièces
au bon
endroit soyez
attentif
les détails ont leur
importance vous avez appris des
choses beaucoup mais pas encore qui a
tué